if you are not a nudist stylist for you
i've been in the fashion and styling
business for
20 years most people know me from queer
eye
i've probably helped literally thousands
of people find their personal style and
find a look that makes them feel good
about themselves
i want you to look in your closet and
decide who do i want to be
what do i want to feel i just want you
to make an
effort this class is different from
anything i've ever done before i will
comprehensively break down
what style is and how the principles
work american men
plaid is not your only option for a
print move on
it is absolutely possible for you to
have great style on any budget
the key is a capsule wardrobe
this is your base this is your
foundation
all of these items can be worn time
after time
and reimagined i devoted my life to
style
because it affected me so greatly as a
child
i so desperately wanted to show who i
really was inside but i couldn't because
of my culture and my faith when i was
seven
i went to my grandad's factory he made
denim
and for the first time i understood
where clothes came from how they were
created
and how they could make me feel and so i
started to experiment with clothes
and my clothes gave me a window into the
world that i could only have dreamt of
i want you to really start to see your
closet as a vehicle to getting what you
want from your life i want you to really
feel something when you get dressed in
the morning
every day know that you've made an
effort be the reason that you're happy
i'm tan france and this is my
[Music]
masterclass
[Music]
you